all right let's talk about bill cosby  and why he's going free this is a  complicated issue but the short version  is  not that he's innocent but that he was  effectively tricked into waving his  fifth amendment rights and that made his  conviction infirm  background is this in 2005 andrea  constand came forward with rape  allegations against bill cosby  this was a few years after the incident  itself  she delayed for personal reasons the  district attorney  who we'll come back to in a second  decided not to prosecute remember this  is in 2005  before scores of women came forward  against cosby and it was not clear that  the prosecutors would be able to get a  conviction against him so the district  attorney bruce castor who is now famous  for representing president trump in the  impeachment hearings decided to  issue a promise to cosby that they  weren't going to go forward with  prosecuting him  continued in part two